you
well it's interesting hazardous cargos
it's actually a story for those in your
audience about a man whose job it is to
drive a flock of penguins across the
country and in the course of a story of
the trunk of penguins overturns which
means actually a real incident i cobbled
out of a newspaper a number of years ago
and sat in my desk for a long time and
walking to work every day or living my
life periodically these penguins would
come back into my mind and the challenge
was to capture the voice of a man who
drives penguins and part of the
challenge of that is there is a famous
writer who I won't mention here who say
you should never write stories about
truck drivers unless there's truck
drivers think like Proust and I think
there's a lot of wisdom in that i am not
a fan of storage but ordinary people who
think in ordinary ways i am deeply
devoted in a big fan of stories but
ordinary people who think in
extraordinary ways not because there are
millions of people out there leading
ordinary lives but Biggie's ordinary
lives don't make very interesting
stories your challenge to find the
extraordinary person who matches the
extraordinary facts of the situation
you're going to explore and often it's
not just a matter of coming up with that
voice but matching that voice to the
facts of the situation
well I think on the one hand fiction is
a very powerful tool to show us the
issues and writers should not be afraid
to explore these questions on the other
hand you don't want to write issue
driven stories and the thing you most
don't want to do is you don't want to
write issue driven storage in which
you've solved the problem or offer an
answer to the issue the distinction I
make and this is purely a matter of
taste but I think if you compare
probably be too great african-american
male novelists of the 20th century
Richard Ryan Ralph Ellison i'm richard
wright is in some sense a more didactic
writer if you look at native son the
first reception native son is a
beautiful lyric work the second is a
lyric work that is driven by issues and
the third is somewhat propaganda can
give you an answer to the question in
contrast to Ralph Ellison who shows you
in its full panorama the challenges of
african-americans in the early 20th
century but doesn't give you any answers
and I think history will show that
Ellison's Invisible Man is a far better
and more lasting work my native son I
think for writers out there you want to
show people the issues or show people
the questions but you don't want to
offer the Masters let them come to the
answers on the road